[Music]
eleven years and five billion dollars in
the making ethiopians are finally able
to switch on electricity produced by
their own giant dam
a welcome distraction for prime minister
abiye ahmed at war with rebel tigrayan
forces in the north
the 145 meter high dam on the nile
river's main tributary the blue null is
designed to hold 74 billion cubic meters
of water but africa's largest
hydroelectric power project is
controversial and it's fiercely opposed
by ethiopia's neighbors
the downstream countries the brothers
the people of egypt and sudan the water
will flow and the world must know that
the dam will not affect them
all that was said about ethiopia seeking
to prevent the flow of water is untrue
and we will not allow the people to
starve or thirst we seek integration
between the three countries and a real
partnership
both egypt and sudan fear the damning of
the blue nile will cause severe water
shortages for them egypt responded on
sunday saying ethiopia is persisting in
its violations of a declaration signed
in 2015.
leaders in cairo say the dam is an
existential threat to the 106 million
egyptians who are almost entirely
reliant on the nile river for irrigation
and drinking water
while sudan first welcomed the dam
project it later voiced similar concerns
about its threat to national security
over the years talks sponsored by the
african union failed and construction
still went ahead the more that we see
events like the one that happened today
begin
to where to emerge the more it becomes
dimmer and dimmer that we can actually
see it as friends and as fellow africans
and resolve this as a purely african
problem
ethiopia says the hydropower generation
is essential to economic development in
africa's second most populous country
both egypt and sudan are still pushing
for a legally binding deal on both the
filling of the giant reservoir and its
operation
[Music]
al jazeera